i just had a big hallelujah the other
day when i was looking at your instagram
and i thought what a cool girl what a
brave girl for you posting you know some
imperfections that we all have you know
what i'm saying why did you decide like
now is the time for me to just
show who i am flaws and all yeah i mean
it's my face you know i i see it every
morning when i look in the mirror every
night before i go to bed and i think
if i can feel comfortable knowing that
my acne might be acting up i mean you
can even see it through my makeup
tonight
like
i mean everyone goes through it i'm 17
right now and that's like prime time for
getting some acne and i feel like if i
can just
be myself on the internet it's really
about having confidence in myself and if
that helps anyone else that makes it 10
times better you know this room full of
women tonight the empowerment and the
powerfulness is mean exactly that you
know what i'm saying finding your voice
feeling comfortable who you are and do
you understand though how many young
girls you can affect by just being you
and just speaking your truth you know
yeah i mean i think to me i had
originally posted it because i felt
really pretty in those pictures and i
wasn't even looking at the pimples but
then hearing other girls stories um
really really made me feel good about it
and it definitely just
concrete like
proof that it's like you just gotta
really be yourself and the more
the more you can have the confidence in
yourself like people are just going to
look at you because well if she can be
confident in herself when she has that
then i can too absolutely and that just
means the world to me the fact that
you're learning this at 17 good job mom
the fact that you're teaching seriously
the fact that you're getting that so
young is a testament to what you know
you guys teach come on in here for a
second we were just talking about how
brave she was her post the other day
when i saw it i was just like
yes yes charlie like you know because so
many girls and especially young girls
don't want to be themselves but she has
such a reach with so many young girls
and to say nope i'm just going to be me
is so awesome i you know that day that
she posted that she was definitely
having a moment about her skin and
getting frustrated and then next thing i
saw her post about it and i was like
absolutely like
just own it like you're gonna get
through it your skin will go through
changes as
all of us and i'm so proud of her for
doing that because i think there's a lot
of
young people that appreciate it that
like wait i always hide mine not even
like even older people were in her
comments saying
i love that she did that like i do the
same thing i want to hide it and let's
just be ourselves so yeah so proud of
her gotta live with the face that you
were given well you got a good one sis
very thankful to her
[Music]